you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and going to do another
set of three puzzles and simply share my
thoughts along the way so in this first
one we're playing as white okay well I
see the answer yes I see the answer
okay this rook is unprotected and this
King is accessible on the C file so we
could actually land a fork with this
retreating move Queen c1 material is
pretty much balanced with the pieces the
pawns or two three four or five it black
is up upon but they have a hanging rook
here that we could take advantage of
yeah yeah this is the answer some other
quick thoughts that I had when I
initially looked at the position am i I
kind of focused immediately on b7
because I saw this but it's well
supported I saw this rook is kind of out
of play I saw this this night is out of
play and if there isn't something
happening here I kind of next then went
to yeah I went to looking at the C file
and giving some kind of a check and I
think lastly I noticed though the rook
is also on h6 unprotected so this'll be
uh a simple one a fork and then just
winning a piece okay that was a pretty
simple start to this group of three
let's try a number two okay all right
first thing to know first thing I'm
noting is what exactly there's an idea
of the Horowitz bishops with Bishop c5
this threatens multiple mates the most
direct one with Bishop c5 is queen of to
game over in how to parry that if Queen
here that would fall for Queen takes
Knight pawn takes Queen Bishop h3
controlling the two light squares see
when the bishop is playing here controls
the light this rook is covering all
these squares so if I could somehow
manage to guard these two light squares
Bishop h3 would do that so this is
certainly an idea and a top candidate
right away from me Bishop c5 Queen here
I'll take the knight and then play
Bishop h3 however suppose Bishop c5 and
the Queen defends f2 in a different way
suppose Queen to d2 Oh what's what's
what's the big idea then what it still
be Queen takes Knight I'm not so sure at
that point because the Queen can block
on g2 should wish of h3 happens so
Bishop c5 Queen d2 Queen takes Knight
pawn takes Knight Bishop h3 there's
Queen g2 something that she would do
different from the D 2 square then R
when compared to the e 1 square its
Queen e1 defends about f2 and this G 2
square
assuming Queen e1 only defends f2 Queen
d2 defends f2 Angie - I still think that
this is correct I know maybe I should be
looking first at the or the checking
moves but I don't see really a good
checking move for move number 1
these squares are already covered well
you know I'm not really seeing I think
that this is the first move but I have
to come up with something different for
Queen to d2 Bishop c5 Queen d2 what
would I do there it seems like
everything's covered when the Queen gets
to play to d2 oh you know what it is
probably I'm seeing it though it's
important I think to take this knight
immediately if Queen takes Bishop
there's made on the spot the Queen e1
and so that's going to force pawn takes
Bishop and then and then only after the
knight has been removed
can we play Bishop to c5 and how is this
different well this defensive move of
Queen to d2 can now be met with Queen
takes pawn right away Bishop takes pawn
takes this Queen is immediately
restricted to f3 if she ever moves for
just a moment from defending here I
could take here immediately with check
and I think that that's going to be
decisive Bishop takes Knight pawn takes
Bishop c5 and how are you stopping
Queen f2 mate Queen d2 we take the pawn
with check this then forces Queen to f2
and then we take the Queen so one more
consideration Bishop takes pawn takes
Bishop c5 let's say the King bolts King
to g2 pretty sure he's just going to get
hunted down and yeah he will get hunted
down Bishop takes pawn takes
excuse me Bishop c5 let me back up let's
not get ahead of myself Bishop takes
Knight has moved one pawn takes Bishop
c5 and suppose King g2 we immediately
come over to the G file knowing that if
the King goes to the H file we can
like Queen age 6 game over and if the
King returns to f1 we still have this
battery going on Queen f2 game over so I
believe that this is the key first move
it is now only at this point Bishop c5
that's correct
and they are going for this variation we
have a check and mate next okay all
right
yes very tempting and certainly
important to know this tactical motif
right here
we're playing Bishop c5 let me just
bring up the analysis board right here
so this was the start position very
tempting is this move threatening mate
right away but Queen d2 holds everything
Queen e1 not so much because of this and
then this and that's game over but Queen
d2 defends f2 defends g2 so this idea is
no longer working because the Queen can
interpose on g2 but still something to
be aware of for sure these ideas Bishop
c5 threatens mate and this making to
threat if white is not careful with how
exactly to defend f2 okay let's try
puzzle two playing his team way this is
my first stop right here because it just
pulls the king out and also makes him
more vulnerable to ensuing checks with
Queen d5 Queen h5 rook f4 it's probably
the first move
guys are not playing really the rook and
the bishop given a move by black there's
not really good check so I have my eye
on potentially a silent move as a first
move but I'm still looking at the most
direct stuff of Bishop takes pawn King
takes as otherwise we're just taking a
rook and well right now black is up the
exchange but if we could win a full rook
that'll be sufficient to solve this so
Bishop takes King has to take where
would we go from there
Queen d5 could be met with rook block I
don't really like that Bishop takes King
here there's Queen h5 uh-huh probably
heading in the right direction with that
one because that place is a pretty
strong restriction on our limits blacks
responses in a great way because I'm
Heying up that rook
if I did it some silent move let me just
maybe touch on this real quick if I made
a move like rook F for Queen f3 or queen
h5 I think black is given this one
moment to say you know what I'll give
some material up just to parry the
threat against f7 and I'll do that by
playing rook be six and it basically
kills the light square attack so I think
that these silent moves are just not
working it's worth mentioning yes this
Bishop is hanging but it is protected
indirectly if it was black to move Queen
takes bishop is met with this just
bishop takes and then I take the Queen
so I'm ruling out these silent moves as
the first move and I'm still I'm still
focused on this is the first move I
believe it will be the correct start but
I need to see it through to its end
chop chop where to go from there rook f4
I don't believe amounts to anything
because of King g8 and then what would
be the great fall up there hmm
oh okay hang on I'm seeing something
with the f8 square right now I'm seeing
this idea where when the replace to f4
there's an idea where if the black King
returns back tries to run away to the
eighth-ranked rook to f8 will be mate
if this rook goes elsewhere so for
example Bishop check King here Queen d5
should rook ie6 be played and then we
have rook F for this might be exactly
what happens when a computer plays
through well when we see the answer I
think we'll have this variation actually
Bishop takes King here Queen d5 rookie
six we have then rook f4 check and if
the King goes to e8 or g8 its rook f8
mate if
King goes somewhere else like well where
would he go with the Queen on d5 the
rook on d6 and the King on f7 rook f4
check doesn't have very many options in
fact a yellow meows one option aside
from the back ranked squares which we
have covered because of rook f8 his only
other option from f7 would be to go to
g6 but then we can play Queen f5 check
knowing our rook is on f4 at this point
Queen f5 check King h6 and then finally
rook to h4 mate bishop check King here
Queen d5 I have rookie 6 covered is
there something else to consider I don't
think so I think we're going to have
that same mating pattern if the King
comes out right away
Bishop checking here Queen d5 the King
steps up we have the rook coming over
and giving check to whatever square the
King comes to and basically walking over
in mating the King as he goes to the age
file so I think that this is it and
we'll probably see the variation where
the King goes to the back rank we'll
find out that is correct
Queen d5 nice centralization and it's
important that it takes away this g8
escape square ok so the king is going in
this direction and now we have a mate in
a few let me just make sure I see a mate
in three there are four at least
is there something faster rook g4 if
King here Queen g5 is mate there's rook
g4 if the King comes back here we have
rook f4 Queen f5 rook h4 me is there
something faster is the only thing I'm
questioning let's see I don't really
think that there is
I'm gonna go with rook G for you know
that'll lead to that I'll lead to the
mate let me just bring up the analysis
board to show a variation I was talking
about here so we started here chop-chop
Queen check if the rook blocked they're
vulnerable in the back rink now after
rook f4 King here or King here will be
met with the brook f8 and well in the
final position the King went here check
and then the problem was solved but if
he's going here that would be mate and
if he's going here
is there something faster I'm not really
seeing it if there is yeah I think it
would just be rigged up for Queen of
five and then rook h4 okay let's try one
last one see if we go three for three
team white it's probably a mate how
exactly to mate given time if it is
black to move there are no checks I'm
not thinking about winning pieces in
this type of position I see that the
king is currently only having these two
squares as save squares okay so actually
what this means
one way that I'm looking at this right
now is if I could teleport the rook to
e6 this might not be a bad way to think
about things if you could get the rook
to e6 that's me this rook right here
it's important that this rook is cutting
off these fifth-ranked squares but this
guy here if he could somehow get to e6
that's game over
giving check and he stops king to e7 so
having said that this is maybe a start
with rook to f1 but I'm already gonna
scratch that actually because why well
there is Bishop block and then he's he's
just a long way off from contributing
how about just the one quiet move yeah
that's what it is it's just a straight
shot to the e6 square huh how do you
like that yeah this is a mountain one
two three a million three huh yeah
okay so just factoring in this idea
where black doesn't have anything even
if it was their move they're not able to
hurt you there's no mate threat against
white there's no not even a checking
move against white if we could somehow
get the rook here and we can I think the
first move is just going to be rook to
e1 and the only way to stop rook here
mate next is to play Bishop d5 defending
or bishop here blocking bishop bishop d5
or bishop e4 bishop before we just take
and then here next is me and if bishop
here well there's two ways we could take
but I believe best will be to take with
this rook taking with the bishop this
allows King takes pawn we want to keep
this position as is with the bishop and
pawn so I think that we're just going to
have rook here and maybe it'll already
say that the puzzle is solved not quite
sure I'm just double-checking rook to e1
bishop d5 rook takes and there's no way
to parry rookie six mate next you know
that should be it okay they are taking
it further and they're just blocking
okay yeah they're just gonna play it out
okay not bad okay so not the most
difficult of not the most difficult set
of three that I've encountered that's
for sure but as usual feel free to share
how you did with these three in the
comments section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it and
you're having a good day that's all for
now
take care
you